6 42 it's Thursday morning the pandemic
had a major impact on student test
scores a lot of children have fallen
behind the curve for students who maybe
need a little extra boost CCSD is now
offering free tutoring online so great
it's free and I think we can all use a
little help right even now Candice
Charles joining us live from The
Newsroom to talk about how this program
is called paper how it works Candace
good morning
especially free tutoring Heather I think
that's essential for anybody who needs
help good morning to you good morning
folks it really is simple to use this is
the dashboard I'm already signed on you
can go right over here to type in the
question to a map tutor U.S history
tutor any question that you have in any
subject or you can even upload your
writing and get annotated feedback right
away it's going to just go ahead and go
to a chat you can go right to the chat
at the top and you'll get to talk to a
live tutor in seconds really cool really
simple for not only students to use but
also parents CCSD shout out 6 million
bucks from their color relief funding to
get paper into schools at the beginning
of the school year the hope is to help
students bounce back after the pandemic
paper is now accessible to all students
in the district students and teachers at
Swanson Middle School have been trained
on how to use it and the principal tells
me the transition has been smooth
with the pandemic they were online and
so they were used to chatting with their
teacher or classmates so this is just
another teacher another tutor the help
we know students talk in text a language
and so we meet them where they're where
they're at
yeah and that's essential and paper is
available in multiple languages look at
this really cool change it to French
really quickly and there you have we
right and this is really easy to find
CCSD students already have it on their
clever dashboard so no need to download
but if you want to find out more details
about paper you can go to our website
8newsnow.com for now live in The
Newsroom I'm Candace Charles 8 News Now